that combination narcissistic trump  uh enamored  egomaniac low information trump  supporters who will do whatever he says  and fall for whatever and then a  republican party that whatever they  believe privately isn't getting in the  way of what donald trump is doing  that is a very disturbing situation and  you could  see circumstances in which if they do  well in 22  if they take the house they're almost  certainly impeaching joe biden without  question it won't he won't get convicted  in the senate but almost certainly and  it may be the exact boost to what we are  hoping is a dying movement in trumpism  doing well in 22 could be the exact type  of boost that will make 23 to 25 the  pure that that legislative session  crazier than even what was going on  under obama